[Music]
[Applause]
happy Halloween everybody I hope you
enjoyed a skit with Michael Myers for a
movie that doesn't have Michael Myers
welcome to my review of Halloween three
season of the which every single
Halloween for the past three years in a
row I've reviewed one of the Halloween
films on October 31st and this year
we're talking about the very first one
that decided to scrap the character of
Michael Myers entirely and go forth with
a brand new narrative and I want to
address something really quick for
anyone who might be confused last year
in my Halloween 2 review I did say I
wanted to review every Halloween film
leading up to the new one this year
but I realized kind of after saying that
that that would have just gotten very
tiring after a while also I decided I
would go forth with the pre-1970 series
because I felt that there wasn't enough
entertainment like that on YouTube there
wasn't enough people talking about older
films and so I wanted to try to add to
that conversation as well and still
review these Halloween films when
Halloween rolls around now I respect the
filmmakers for trying to do something
different Halloween to said okay Michael
Myers you're done so with Halloween 3
they decided to go forth with this new
idea where every single Halloween they
would have a new Halloween themed movie
within this franchise with different
adventures that's potentially a really
good idea and that might have worked if
they made a good movie but they didn't
we got Halloween 3 season of the witch
now I don't want to diminish the fact
that this film actually does have a
considerable amount of admirers people
over the years have felt that the movies
underappreciated or that it got a bad
rap well I can definitely understand
that I really don't agree I think this
is a pretty terrible film largely
because it's incredibly boring and
that's one of the greatest sins a movie
can make if you saw my review of Manos
the hands of fate you would have heard
my friend Joe say that a movie that's
just nothing that's just bland and
barely interesting at all it's almost
worse than if the film was like the room
or Manos the hands of fate at least when
it's bad like that you get excited about
talking about it a movie like Halloween
3 season of the witch it's a chore to
get through one of the prime
reasons the film is so mundane is
because our lead character Daniel played
by Tom Atkins is one of the worst
protagonists ever in a large film like
this he's apparently a doctor although
this career never really comes into play
throughout the film he essentially
spends the entire film asking other
people to help him what really is his
motivation for investigating this
company in the film that's developing
these masks that we eventually learn are
very dangerous they have this very evil
plan they're going to murder a bunch of
children on Halloween Day what is his
motivation for being there I'll tell you
what it is he wants to get some action
that's right
this character is the embodiment of
everything wrong with male protagonists
in the 1980s this is not a disservice to
Tom Atkins the actor he was working with
a material he was given with I'm talking
about the character as he has written in
the screenplay by far creepier than
anything in any Halloween film those are
in the cabinet and there's milk and
cookies in the fridge I think I should
have married you Angus
this guy spends the majority of the film
flirting with his co-workers asking them
to help him with his investigation that
he has no real motivation for being on
and saying he'll take them out to dinner
and weird creepy things like that
constantly alright but this is gonna
cost you some serious dinners when you
get back I'm always ready for dinner
with you he spends almost the entire
first act having sex with this girl
there's a 24-year age difference between
these actors and if that's not really
fucking creepy I don't know what is this
movie got under my skin but in all the
wrong ways I mean they have sex twice
before he even asks her how old she is
wait wait wait my other big issue with
Halloween 3 is that it seems to think
it's gore is very horrifying it has so
many over-the-top sequences Carpenter's
first film was so subtle he made the
mistake of assuming audiences wanted
more gore in the second film when we
really didn't need it and this film
tries to top even that and it becomes
comical the deaths in this movie are
hilarious
[Music]
so we already know this is a sequel to
the previous two Halloween films because
of the title but it also has strange
meta in universe references to the fact
that Halloween is a movie almost like
it's not actually a sequel and we're
watching people in our world who
recognize what Halloween is it comes on
the television twice as referenced as an
immortal classic the immortal classic
followed by the big giveaway at night
towards the end of the film when Daniels
all tied up in this facility it's
playing on the television we actually
hear the music and we see Jamie Lee
Curtis it's just a very odd choice there
are so many choices like that that take
me out of the film at every turn the
strange protagonist the weird
relationship how boring he is the gore
that's so over-the-top and then the fact
that it references Halloween existing
but it's also a sequel what is this film
I understand why some people have a
respect for it because it does take a
lot of risks like that but for myself
they didn't pay off
this film is written and directed by
Tommy Lee Wallace who now is most known
for directing the it miniseries with Tim
Curry he also directed the sequel to
John Carpenter's vampires I think the
reason this movie looks as good as it
does is because Dean condi lends dit the
brilliant cinematographer who helmed so
many great films so at least the movie
looks good it's one of the best parts of
the film is that it's a it's beautifully
shot there are some sequences that do
put me on edge whenever that jingle
comes on that's based off of London
Bridge is falling down which is
extremely annoying after a while there
are times where it starts to up beat the
tempo and it gets higher and higher and
we're experiencing something horrific
and sometimes that can be effective but
I couldn't care less about the
super-powered guys walking around in
suits murdering people in hilarious ways
they were never once frightening and
again I must reference the protagonists
the man and woman were supposed to be
following if I don't give a shit about
them I'm not gonna care about the rest
of the movie and they're just so
painfully boring I mean this guy's best
skill is throwing a Halloween mask onto
a camera instantly on his first try
I'm gonna gonna do a few spoilers here
for Halloween 3 you've been warned
what's revealed about this corporation
is that like the planetary alignments
happening and they're going to be
killing all these children as some sort
of witchcraft sacrifice the biggest
issue I have with this is that it takes
so long for this to be revealed the
entirety of the film is based around the
fact that we are supposed to be scared
of these guys in suits and every once in
a while somebody dies in a really
hilarious over-the-top death it takes so
long to reveal what's actually going on
that once it's revealed I've lost
complete interest in the film and even
though it might add a little bit of a
guilty pleasure storyline that I could
kind of like just for the fact that it's
so insane it just took so long to get
there and when these two are sneaking
around throughout this facility and they
use this cart they stand behind it and
wheel it to a safe place well all of the
villains are in another room what's more
inconspicuous two people walking by or a
cart moving on its own look I don't
understand how it's like a Looney Tunes
scene the laser beams blasting the main
villain while he smiles is just fucking
funny when it's revealed that the girl
has become a cyborg
it's absolutely atrocious even without
Michael Myers this still could have been
an interesting Halloween film they did
take some risks and I admire the fact
they did try to propel the story in a
different direction all that being said
I find the story they chose insanely
boring I'm gonna give Halloween 3 season
of the witch a d-minus guys thank you so
much for watching this year's Halloween
special I had a blast doing these videos
my friends and my wife we really enjoyed
making those videos so thank you so much
for watching and for supporting as
always I have heard your requests to
review the new show the haunting of Hill
House and I did watch it I finally just
yesterday finished episode 10 I'll be
reviewing that soon but I do need to
take a little bit of a break because I
have reviewed and edited so many
different videos over the past few weeks
but that video will be out very soon so
look forward to that guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon and if you
like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]